okay it is a beautiful day outside it's
like like 71 degrees outside right now
and we have the windows open in the
house and there's like a breeze blowing
through and we're getting ready to watch
full metal alchemist they can't hold on
your junk food why because we can so
okay so okay so we're vendors in game
all right here's here's what okay here's
what happens I am a vicar's in game okay
you know what I'm gonna call it right
now I'm gonna call it right now
a vendors in game is gonna break the
record the box office record it's gonna
make three billion dollars it's gonna
make three billion dollars cuz this is
the end of it all right like it was do
okay it was one thing like Avengers
Avengers infinity war people were like
okay it's gonna like we knew it was
gonna do well but then it's like a
infinity war right like it's the first
half of the movie so it's like okay like
the second half is like when everything
happens right like this way it always is
when it comes to like two parties like
the second half is where everything
happens so much like it's like okay I
saw sim here thinking about this and I
was like because here's the problem that
I've had and here's a problem I think
everybody has is people are looking
despite the fact that they know they're
two different movies people are looking
at like infinity war and endgame has two
distinctly different movies as if
they're they're they're as if like time
will pass between one and the other but
they're basically like like the rumor it
was part one it was part two like it was
designed to tell one cohesive story and
it still is the name is just different
and so so I'm gonna sit here thinking
about that I was like okay so what if
they plastered both movies together
right like what if this was released in
the same way is like one of the Lord of
the Rings movies it's like some
gargantuan four and a half hour
you know craziness but like not as bored
and so I was like okay so like you know
what what what happens if it were
released that way and so I was sort of
think about that I was like will be the
next logical step right like you have
what's left of the superheroes like
what's the next logical step alright so
so my first thought was they're
basically beaten and defeated right so
it's like age of Ultron the comic book
bright like age of Ultron they come up
with picks up and like Ultron's conquer
the world Captain America is cowering in
the corner crying you know and like
nobody knows what to do like you know
what is it one of the I think it's
Hawkeye or somebody like rescue
spider-man like it's it's literally like
like the end times right like okay it's
like everybody's gonna dock
this is the it this is this you know
it's the end it's the Avengers version
of Days of Future past and so I was
always sitting thing about that I was
like okay what's the next step well
Captain America and in the MCU is always
like there's always a way to win right
like that's the one thing they've hit at
consistently he's always like there's
always a way to win and always a way to
do it the right way but like now they
have Carol Danvers alright so careless
so here's here's what's gonna happen
right here's here's exactly what I think
now
so carol danvers is gonna show up within
the first like twenty to thirty minutes
of the movie and the reason why is
because it's literally gonna be like
after the after the the end craft of the
beginning of the movie the ending of of
infinity war when they were all just
kind of like okay so like basically the
snap happened and like Thor screwed up
and didn't do like the most intelligent
thing which was so like hit him in the
head which is what anybody would have
done but you want to know you want to
like send someone a warning or wound
them you shoot them in his chest if you
want to put him down for the count you
shoot them in the head come on Thor it's
killing 101 like you've been doing this
long enough so so so I was sitting there
thinking about that and I was like okay
so like literally after that they're all
gonna go back to Avengers mansion and
like assess the damage right and like
ask the question like what's our next
step gonna be and then Carol Danvers is
gonna show up and Carol Danvers is gonna
give them the hope that like hey we
could possibly win because like she's so
strong and like she's from space which I
guess automatically makes you stronger
and so she's like okay so so loser
they're gonna grab Carol Danvers and
they're gonna go find Thanos on his
planet right like they're gonna go find
Alice now here's the thing I was always
sitting or thinking about this and I was
like okay but like it's one thing to
believe they can do that it's another
for to matter right like it's not afford
to have any any kind of bearing
whatsoever so I'm flipping through
Instagram and Robert Downey jr. has this
like clip on Instagram TV which nobody
uses and and it's basically like you
know what if they like what if the
heroes failed and I started thinking
about that and it's like okay like but
that basically it's like giant Robert
Downey jr. saying and then like the most
obvious way possible the heroes are
going to fail they're not going to win
and it's like okay but like they have to
win though so how do you not win and win
at the same time like how do you do that
time-travel shenanigans so I was sitting
thinking about that I was like okay so
here's what they're gonna do so they're
good so Carol Danvers is gonna show up
on earth you know she's gonna be like
hey guys like stop feeling so bad you
know
when but do it like the Mosel she's
gonna say that like the most badass way
possible in a way the Captain America
can't and so basically like like they're
you know they're gonna grab krill
danvers but they're gonna go to Thanos
home planet and they're gonna fight him
and they're gonna kill him right like
they're gonna they're gonna kill thanos
in the first half of the movie and then
they're gonna grab the Infinity Gauntlet
and then they're gonna try to undo it
and it's not gonna work because the
Infinity stones are broken like they're
damaged right like because because we
know they're borrowing heavily from
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four right
like jon is I'm not not papers famous
for hit pins offenders in New Avengers
right like anybody an SCC hmm this is
why I pays to read comics 25 years
reading comics I've seen it all so so
here is here so and Jonathan Hickman's
Avengers and New Avengers the incursions
happen whatever go watch my video on the
incursion if you want to know what it is
anyway
universes are colliding so they give
Captain America the Infinity Gauntlet
they say push that Universal way he
successfully doesn't it but the Infinity
stones shatter and the time stone
vanishes and so I think with with all
the other Infinity stones being cracked
it basically kind of carries over from
the comic books the fact that we already
knew that the Infinity stones can be
destroyed and so carry that over into
the MCU say the snap was too powerful it
wiped out it wiped out half the life in
the universe but destroy the Infinity
stones at the same time now if that's
the case if it destroyed the Infinity
stones at the same time then what that
does is it says okay Thanos is now dead
but these but the snap cannot be undone
like the snap cannot be fixed there's no
way to undo that and so it's like okay
so like that's how the heroes lose it's
like they can't they can't do anything
can't do anything my Panthers gone all
the heroes who do who got dusted are all
gone now that begs the question how do
they save the day
right like how do they make how do they
make everything work so so then I
started thinking about that and I'm
actually thinking about that right now
and I started thinking about that and I
was like okay because the one thing
everybody's hitting on right like like
the one thing like every youtuber
everybody's talking about is like Scott
Lang is the key to win it all right now
from there what it does is it like I
would say it goes into the quantum realm
with a question see here's the question
how does the quantum realm allow them to
like time-travel see like that's the
question how does the quantum realm
allow them in how do you how do you go
into the quantum realm and come out
how many times have worked in the
quantum realm unless unless
oh that's good okay unless they're
treating the quantum realm like the
speedforce
okay uh break away from in-game for
second right okay and DC Comics you have
the Speed Force what's the speed force
it's the flash equivalent of like
Batman's prep time like how can Batman
do it who cares he's got prep time like
he prepped for a thing that he couldn't
possibly know was going to happen but he
did and he won like that's that's
literally that's literally like Batman
in a nutshell the Speed Force in DC
Comics the way this works is you
essentially have like this this energy
source right like it's the afterlife of
the speedsters and it's where they go
when they die but the Speed Force was
created by Barry Allen and it kept
growing as he kept running and so when
the time came during crisis on Infinite
Earths when he died he joined the Speed
Force but because of the fact that he'd
been running so much the Speed Force had
been growing essentially like
exponentially the more the Speed Force
crew the more it expanded throughout not
just the existing universe but the
multiverse and all time throughout the
multiverse which is how speedsters can
time travel is how they can basically
jump from from the present to the past
by using the Speed Force and so it's
like it's like okay so what if they did
that with a quantum realm right like
what if the quantum realm is like this
realm that expands not just through
space but through time and so it's like
the negative zone right so like imagine
your house you know imagine like like
every room in your house right like
every room with a door so like a closet
and a bedroom and a pantry and all that
kind of stuff
imagine those are all universes and
every everything else in your house all
the other space in your house is the
quantum realm right like you can access
any point in time using the quantum
realm so literally if the quantum realm
basically if it's if it's this dimension
that starts at the very beginning of
time and ends at the very end of time
the end of the universe essentially then
you could enter the quantum realm and
like every every single moment and the
history of the universe is a hallway of
doors you can walk down five doors open
that door and your five years ago you
can walk down ten doors open the door
and you're 10 years ago like you can
literally go through any point in time
by access into quantum well now how they
know whether whether professor Hulk ok
professor ho ok
so I bet professor Hawkins oh well who
for
it out like I bet Tony Stark is the one
that gives them access because here's
the thing if they if they if they sit
down and they say okay we failed we have
to find a way to work Scott Lang has to
somehow be able to exit the quantum
realm how he does that I don't know but
like Scott Lang somehow gets out right
and basically says hey look there's this
place called the quantum realm I've been
exploring it and like here's what it can
do maybe Scott Lang is the one who
realized what they can do but Scott Lang
is like here's what we can do
like literally use the quantum realm and
just surf it like a wave and just get
like ride it all the way back to like
when Thanos first when Thanos first got
the infinite ego when Thanos first got
the Infinity going okay so literally
what they do is they ride all the way
back they say so they say they use they
use the quantum realm this dimension
that permeates all space and time they
use a quantum realm travel all the way
back to the past to the point when you
have to the to the point either when
when Thanos first qcf it at some point
in the past and basically fight and kill
thanos but okay but see like here's
here's the okay see that doesn't make
any sense though because if they travel
back okay say they traveled back to the
Battle of Wakanda and they fought Thanos
well okay that'd be lackluster if Thor
is like hey the mistake I made before is
I didn't even so you're talking about
doubles of everybody but I feel like
they would have to avoid themselves in
order to set like he from screwed
screwing at the timestream okay so they
travel they travel to the past
they travel they travel to the past and
they take the Infinity stones they
travel they travel to the past and they
kill thanos or they disable the Infinity
stones or they destroy the Infinity
stones okay because here's the thing
like we were told the big battle is
gonna be in Wakanda right like the big
band the big Donnell is gonna be in what
kondal like it's basically to be like a
like part two but there's gonna be like
look Honda over again like the do over
in Wakanda so you send them back to the
past you have them deep power the
Infinity stones you sit it back to the
past and you have them screw up the
Infinity Gauntlet Finity stones oh that
works you send the Avengers back into
the past they do something they replace
an infinity war infinity war okay you
have them do you have them then Thanos
needs all the Infinity stones working
together
my girlfriend's entertained right now
Thanos needs all the Infinity stones you
take the plot from infinity war that's
what you do okay Thanos needs all the
Infinity stones in order to be able to
initiate the snap right why not without
half-life the universe he needs all that
power so give them a faked stone like go
back in the past okay so okay so you
have the Infinity Gauntlet story in
Marvel Comics right and then you have
Infinity Ward which of the following an
infinity war is a story where the evil
persona of Adam warlock basically like
grabs the Infinity Gauntlet and kind of
goes mad with power but what you end up
finding out is that Adam warlock had
created the infinity watch so like moon
dragon the daughter of Drax the
destroyer pip the troll who's kind of
funny but not really he held one of the
stones between his toes um
and then like Gamora and then Adam
warlock himself and then fanless was
given the reality stone but when Stano
started to realize what the Magus was
doing what the evil version of Adam
warlock was doing he basically has he
created like a do
look at a perfect duplicate of the
reality stone and gave it to him okay
now here's here's like little he gave it
you gave if the mag is a perfect
duplicate of the reality stone but
Magnus can use the full totality of the
Infinity Gauntlet they go into the past
they take one of the Infinity stones and
they replace it with a fake one and so
when that when the whole event of the
snap happens then Thanos can't initiate
it because he doesn't have the he
doesn't have a fully assembled Infinity
Gauntlet so because he doesn't have a
fully assembled Infinity Gauntlet now
it's just all the superheroes versus
Thanos and then like literally it's all
of them brought back like everybody
everybody makes it back because what
because okay because during it during
the Battle of Wakanda Dan'l's fought
every before all those super heroes on
earth but like Iron Man and nebula and
and like star-lord and all those guys
they were all basically stuck out in
space but because it no they if it was
sort of anyway they were all basically
stuck out in space on Titan but if the
snap never happens they make it back in
time the question is if the snap ever
happens how does Captain Marvel get
there maybe she does maybe she doesn't
get there doesn't play a role in it and
they basically treat but regardless of
how her role plays out the snap never
happens everybody makes it back to earth
Santos versus all of the superheroes so
far
Thanos dies and they went dude that's
how you make it that's why they lose
they win at the same time oh I just
figured it out I am so sure I just I am
so sure I just figured out the plot two
videos in game I am so sure I just
solved the pot two of it is in game I
think I have it I think I have it what
do you think me going I have yet to be
wrong that is true
I guess Jay Garrick during the flash I
have yet to be I have yet to be monk
okay
hmm all right
I guess time will tell we have like a
little under a month so actually exactly
one month now cuz that's March 26 so
yeah alright let's see what happens oh
what happens to Iron Man Iron Man will
probably would I'll probably Captain
America will die I bet have to I bet
Captain America dies in the fight with
fan OHS how much do you wanna bet
Captain America dies in the fight with
Thanos
because Santos gets Thanos gets the
final infinity stone after he
incapacitates Captain America but if
Captain America and all them come okay
what if there's some dots some
duplicates Captain America's - Captain
America is but whatever the case says I
bet Captain America dies and here's the
reason why if Iron Man dies in the MCU
that is just kind of like oh my god man
Iron Man died but like if Captain
America dies it's like it's the death of
freedom like I mean I guarantee as
exactly what that's I think - America
dying would be far more impactful then
like Iron Man dying right because like
because I because I mean I don't cuz I'm
at the face of the MCU it's like if they
were to kill spider-man in the comics
like sure he might vanish for a little
bit but like he'll come back but Captain
America's died before Captain America
has been like a Hydra agent which is
cool like hapten a minute like that was
actually a really really cool story
Captain America has been a lot of
different things um Iron Man has never
actually died in the comics he's been be
aged to become a teenager he had the for
sports team
he's faked his death several times Iron
Man's never actually died in the comics
I'm pretty sure but a lot of other
people have not either uh anyway I think
Iron Man will live Captain America I
think will definitely die like I think
he'll die in the fight against Stannis
like he'll be like like it'll be like I
have to solve this fight on my own
but anyway they needed might be one of
those things we like backs hand his
shields to pieces and like one of the
pieces gets caught in his face use over
and dies I have no idea but I think
hazard America will die anyway guys ah
if you are no here to comment explain
make sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob pork you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]